[Music]
hey guys I'm Vaughn I'm a tasty producer
here in New York called
I love chocolate cake I'm on my way to
the store right now to buy chocolate
cake it's a box cake mix and I'm gonna
see if I can make a homemade version
that rivals it I'm gonna have a taste
test with some people at the office and
I guess they'll be the judge let's get
chocolaty you know there's nothing
inherently wrong with box cake it's
great if you're in a pinch and it's
lovely starting off point for your cakes
for the purposes of my taste test I'm
gonna follow the instructions exactly as
they are on the package however there
are a lot of really really great ways to
elevate a boxed cake my mama is a
fantastic baker and my dad for some
reason loves boxed yellow cake so
growing up she taught me to replace the
water with milk and the oil with butter
and that higher fat content really helps
the texture of the cake because box cake
can be a little bit dry
[Music]
there's a lot of ways to really elevate
your box cake so that it tastes homemade
it does dome up quite a bit when you
bake it so I'm gonna just cut that off
because I really want all the cakes to
look pretty similar for my cake tasting
I'm using canned frosting for that
ultimate store-bought experience but
another way to make boxed cake tastes
even better is with homemade buttercream
which is like the easiest thing in the
world to make in my humble opinion the
best way to make any cake look really
nice as fresh fruit on top go from zero
to hero in no time flat not bad box cake
it's like putting lipstick on a pig our
culinary team at tasty led by my
wonderful friend Claire worked really
hard on developing this amazing recipe
for the ultimate chocolate cake hmm this
is kind of embarrassing but I actually
cried the first time I tasted it I wish
I was kidding the star of this cake is
obviously the chocolate but there are
some really important supporting roles
that help that chocolate shine the stout
and the espresso powder adds so much
depth to this cake it really gives it
such a boost that's gonna make you feel
like wow what is in this cake creaming
the butter and sugar is a super
important process in any cake that
you're gonna make because when you cream
together butter and sugar you're adding
air into the butter and then the sugars
holding onto that air and then that's
gonna give our cake really nice
structure now I didn't do this for the
box cake because it's box cake but I
really like to crack my eggs into a
separate Bowl just in case you get a bad
egg and adding them one at a time is
important so that everything gets nice
and incorporated okay don't freak out
but we're gonna add some mayonnaise
we're only using half a cup you're not
gonna taste it and it's gonna create the
most sinfully moist cake you've ever had
I apologize for my casual use of the
phrase sinfully moist we're gonna switch
off adding the dry in the wet
ingredients in stages because mainly you
just want to get all the food all over
your kitchen
that looks so good we're also gonna add
chocolate chunks to the cake and it's
just another little element of surprise
when people bite into it they're gonna
get that fudgy fudgy cake they're gonna
get the nice light buttercream and then
they're gonna have that snap from the
chocolate so we're gonna make sure
everything's evenly distributed and it's
time to bake as you can see they kind of
start to dome but then flatten out as
they bake and then you'll know they're
done when a toothpick comes out clean
it's super smooth almost like dare I say
butter in the past few weeks I've
consumed more buttercream than any human
being should ever consume ever but that
is because this frosting is so light
fluffy and delicious the best thing
about it is that it's not overly sweet
and it complements the cake very well
it's also really smooth which makes it
amazing for decorating which is
everybody's favorite part well you know
besides the whole eating thing now it's
time to have some fun I mean this is the
part where you can get as creative as
you want you can take it as simplistic
as you want just make sure to put enough
buttercream in between all those layers
that when you cut it you got some really
nice distinction I really want to wow
people at this cake tasting so I'm using
a dough scraper to smooth out the sides
I'm adding a ganache drip down the sides
of the cake and then I'm gonna pipe a
little bit of a border at the bottom and
add the fruit on top and I guess snow
cake is complete without the world's
largest strawberry
I think it looks pretty good and I think
we're ready to go up against a
store-bought cake
and a box cake here we go
[Music]
whoa I wouldn't hire why would I waste
my time on any other cake that's a lot
so
the first one the first one was it's
just the best chocolate cake I've ever
okay guys we have our three cakes here
now let's boogie though the homemade
cake took a little bit longer to make it
definitely was the best experience of
all three who taste the texture far
outweigh that of the box cake and the
store-bought cake you cannot get a
better more moist dare I say cake well
we're talking about chocolate cake you
gotta use the word moist there's nothing
else
the world needs cake it would just solve
all of our problems
I'm going to the gym now thank you good
night
[Music]
you
[Music]